yeah dude i want you to fly through that
that explosion you do she's 19 years old
you do yeah
don't [ __ ] up
mr michael bay
listen uh but i want to say a sincere
thank you before we get started to
universal for renting this theater to mr
bay for agreeing to do this q a just
call me bae or mike or whatever i will
just say
i will i will work that in but i a
sincere thank you i really appreciate
this
um i got a lot of questions and then i'm
gonna open it up to the audience um and
i'm just so i read and i obviously could
be wrong that you worked on raiders of
the lost ark at like when you were like
15
doing something
15 and a half
right literally right outside the
universal uh the
black glass building
earthquake was that what the movie yeah
yeah it was in it's the parking lot now
where the uh subway was there was a
little brick building i was saving up
for a car 240z it was a piece of [ __ ] my
parents took to the mechanic they said
don't buy it okay the mechanic said
don't buy but literally i was a summer
job
and uh
i was filing like yoda's house a bog
house uh i was like literally i had a
very mean librarian who was a head guy
there but i'm filing all the stuff
and um
i i was very good at baseball i used to
want to be a pro baseball player and i
was on the softball team so shortstop
and then
apparently i was good and and so they
they gave me an office and in that
little office i was walking by a what do
you call the star wars ii the walker the
walkers
what do you call those things the
walkers the the adat the what
okay i don't even know that name but
whatever right they it was a cool model
you walk by because they had they were
the they would do it like animation
and uh i had this little office and one
day i started getting from london these
gigantic uh
uh storyboards from london uh uh
spielberg's uh razer's lost ark
and i remember seeing you know filing
and i go to my 15 year old buddies and i
said yeah spielberg's doing this movie
called raiders lost ark and i think it's
gonna suck
okay cut two let me cut to
um
uh
a year and a half later i would go to
the movies with my parents like on
sundays
and i went to the gram grommet chinese
theater
and when i saw the movie
i'm like oh my god
that's what i want to do
and got to even later i was like i think
24 i was doing i started directing
videos when i was 22 and then
started doing commercials maybe 25 i
don't know and i get this call from
this agent he goes you got to meet
you got to meet stephen it was stephen
at 3 30 and i think it was about two
o'clock
when i got the call and i'm like stephen
spielberg be there
like oh my god oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
so i was shy all right and
i go to amblyn right here
and um
i s i'm like it's 20 he's 20 feet away
he's sitting at his desk and i i
i'm like oh my god this steven spielberg
oh my god oh my god oh my god what am i
gonna say and i sat down in the chair
and i'm like hey um i followed yours
your storyboards and i really thought
your movie was gonna suck
he started cracking up and
uh um i said and then
when i saw your movie it's it's i
decided that's what i want to do so
there you go anyway
it's a great that's a great story
uh i'm gonna skip i never bought the car
by the way okay
i got a shiraco instead
uh if someone has actually never seen
any of your movies before what is the
first thing you want them watching
that's a good question i mean
it's like a trick question by the way
you know he's very crafty
the first thing
i think watching the performance and
watching the vibe of the movie the
energy of the movie um
uh
you know listen my first movie
bad boys
but let me explain bad boys for a second
because it's it's we were three punk
kids working in in miami and the studio
sony pictures did not believe in the
movie
and
um
i was very young i don't i forgot how
old i was um i'm still 32 but just
remind them okay so you figure out the
age okay and
um
it's like they had no faith in the movie
and there were times when
there was a line producer who was very
mean to us i mean will smith was was
acting and literally the lights were
just shut off in the middle of a take
because it was 12 hours and
um
the crew they were not allowing me to
hire any of my crew
and they're like that's not going to cut
that's not going to work that's not
going to work i'm like well let's just
see let's just see and then i i remember
watching cameron who was a big hero
watching uh
true lies
and he had all this money and one we had
nine million bucks but at least i had
two guys that
and i was working for for my generation
at that time and i said we can make
something funny and
um we took a big risk it's like sony had
no faith in the movie because
two black stars never it never worked
until then until that movie overseas
that's the first movie that broke the
whole mold
and
you know the thing is when you're a
director your first time if you fail
you're done it's over
um
so
it's like there were moments and i'll
tell you like one moment um we're
driving to another location
and
there was there was very little money
the script was terrible but i i improv
with the guys a lot and
you know i'm the type of person where i
did a lot of nike commercials uh and i
worked with a lot of famous athletes
from jordan on down
and
you know when will would do something
that's not funny that's not funny i love
funny okay
and
uh
it's it's uh
there's a there's a
thing where we're driving to another
location and i'm like stop the man stop
the band stop the van and i saw this
this sign and i just saw the light and
um i came up with this shot i said get
the circle track get the circle knight
my line producer comes out
what are you doing michael you got we
can't we're gonna be late tonight i said
this is going to be a trailer shot
they come up with shots very fast
and i put the circle track and i said
guys i just want you to just bend down
and rise up and i'm going to come around
you boom there we go huh
you know the shot
you you do that on a bunch of your
movies though that when you're filming
you i've heard i think it even happened
on the ambulance or you're like this is
a trailer shot which one was that i know
jake told me today when i was doing an
interview he's like we were filming this
and no he thought it was a trailer jake
thought he was getting a trailer shot he
didn't he didn't
uh going uh a few other no but seriously
the cast was amazing in this movie and
you never know what you get you never
know the vibe when you when you put
people together um
you know i think hollywood is like
there's less rehearsal time and we've
had covid
and so you have to basically meet over
phone or zoom and
my thing when you when you work work on
a movie the first week is the most
important
and
i i i like to do a little character
building i like to do a little action a
little fun a little funny and you give a
vibe for the crew you give a vibe for
the actors and what i like most about
movies is
movies take a life of their own and the
actors add more the crew adds more and
it's a very collaborative uh thing
and um
and it was it was a great vibe with the
actors so
i have so many ambulance questions but i
still have a few other things that i
talk a lot so i'm going to try to limit
his question right chris
uh which of your films changed the most
in the editing room versus what you were
expecting and why
okay that's a good question okay it says
head scratchers here um
editing is a very powerful thing um
you know listen when i did bad boys
um
i was doing a technique where i was
cutting faster and my editor my crew was
saying
it's too fast you can't cut like that
you can't cut i said we'll just watch it
and i'm like the younger generation can
process things faster the smaller the
screen the faster you can process the
bigger it gets you have to slow it down
a bit
bad boys if you look at that it's a very
fast-cut movie
um
i got a lot of [ __ ] for it okay by
critics now you look at action movies
today and they've got that same pace
okay
so they give paul greengrass who i love
his movies but they give him the props
but i was doing this well before he was
ever in the career
i agree
but in editing
it was very interesting process when i
did 13 hours and it's a movie that was
true story we had the people the people
died there and i had the people that
were there uh
uh they were there on the on
on station there
they were on the set
and it was weird
to do that movie because i've done a lot
of popcorn movies and it's like you do
the scene like
bam that's the end of the tag of the
scene
and 13 hours was not that way it was it
was like
it was very kind of serious and it had
to be plotting and it had to have
tension
and
i'm thinking oh this is boring it's not
going to work it's not going to work
and
when i started cutting it together and
pietro uh the editor ridley scott's
editor um
he started cutting it together i'm like
wow this is tense this is like but it it
it's actually fun to do something real
uh that has tension
um
and the tension is made through the edit
uh this took a lot of editing
uh pietro cut this as well
uh pietro is italian he's very tough no
michael no you don't need this no no no
no
and okay we could go first you want some
prosciutto week all right come over
let's have some shoes dog
um
but i said pietro we need some money no
no i said pietro we we need to balance
it so i would cut a little i i have my
edit bay in miami at my house and it
links to my office in santa monica so
it's kind of like a it's very
collaborative uh thing it's been like
that for 15 years and i don't know if
you even answered the question
i i i have a fun i just want to
interject and i have so many questions
but i want to share a fun keep saying
that right but i'm just i hope you guys
don't have to go to the bathroom right a
long session this uh i did an editing
room visit and i forget if it was on one
of the transformers i don't know which
what it was but i visited him in the
editing room with a few other reporters
and it was one of the greatest edit
visits of my life because
michael basically kicked out the editor
took control of the avid and played it
so loud that there was paint coming off
the ceiling and hitting us it was
amazing because no one does this like
i've done other edit things and no one
does this it was great um
real question uh have you
has there been a project that you came
really close to the starting line and
ended up not making like it fell apart
for a reason or you know like
were all the projects that you've sort
of gotten involved with have they all
come to fruition
no but i'm forgetting i mean listen i'm
old i'm actually 32. okay
um
normally the movies are not necessarily
scripts i've been given their scripts
that i develop like i'll write my own
action i never try to take any writer
credit i like working with writers i add
funny i can't rob with actors i i'm i'm
spacing on your question i don't know
sure i can i can i can call you all guys
later and emails and we can i can tell
you the answer right you have some in in
all your movies you have amazing shots
when you think back on
all the shots you've done is there one
or two that really stand out as i can't
believe we did this and i still don't
know how we did this
these are stumpers
yeah there's a shot in pearl harbor
where it's the most complicated
explosion ever done to film it has 350
effects
bombs that are going off dynamite in the
water seven gigantic old battleships
at pearl harbor
we have 20 planes in the air that are
antique planes flying in circles we have
the puffy clouds where you have to shoot
in between the sun
uh you have a couple lifeboats with with
real stunt people in there you have to
shut a freeway that is three three and a
half miles away
um all this has to be coordinated
and you have 12 cameras
and if the life goes go by the dynamite
they can get killed and so there's a lot
going on
it took three and a half months to have
them rig this
uh this explosion
multiple 350 events in seven seconds so
that was probably the toughest shot of
my life
it went uh
you can see on the making of and i kept
it in there where i go ballistic
because what i'm trying to show is the
safety that it takes and then the safety
stops with me
and they were crossing what we call the
line of death and i just i start yelling
at this lifeboat with my megaphone full
voice because there is real dynamite in
the water and they could die
um
so i left that in the making of but this
shot was very successful we did set an
eyelid on fire but we put it out um
there you go you used on this uh you're
a big fan of red cameras and i'm curious
can you talk about some of the cameras
like your progression of cameras that
you've enjoyed using starting with bad
boys is there like can you sort of talk
about how you picked your favorites and
the ones you wanted to use so i'm a big
film guy i like i like shooting film i
like nolan likes shooting film um
but
there's the thing when you went digital
the the the the labs are dying and there
are very few labs and look at the guys
nodding okay the guy with a big big gulp
you're tired now are you tired do you
have to go to the bathroom
yeah you
you
okay good
i'm kidding i'm kidding okay
um
so
um
big film guy but the problem is
panavision doesn't uh
those are those are cameras but they
don't develop them enough they're so
unergonomic okay and they're they're
ugly looking and they just they're just
don't fit your body and they
uh
you know i i
did film and then like we
airy creates the uh 235 which is a
handheld they came they had their
engineers come to one of my sets
because i knew that i wanted a small
camera that was a very small camera and
i had them develop these handles on the
side it's the first time they've ever
had double handles like handlebars
and it's small enough you can maneuver
and run with it
um
then you know you have red coming into
the situation and i'm thinking oh
digital sucks and
um but it's gotten better and it's
gotten smaller and
you know 13 hours
i did with the dion bibi the director of
photography who's won the oscar for
memoirs of the geisha um
great guy to work with he literally has
the best hair you've ever had yet i mean
i'm like i'm dirty after a shoot because
i'm i'm the type of guy spreading the
blood i'm like holding camera and he is
always just calm and
perfectly not not a dust thing on him
but
what digital gives you is it gives you
uh
it's smaller it's more sensitive to
light so it's less light at night so
it's cheaper um film takes a lot more
you know firepower and it's a lot more
expensive if you're doing night so 13
hours was shooting during night blue
do you guys care about stuff i care
about this stuff do they so like night
night blue okay 13 hours so night blue
what i call it's right when the sun
drops we're shooting in malta
right when it goes over the horizon
you've got the the sky that goes it
starts to go cobalt and you have it was
during summer time so you have about
like 18 minutes okay so i've got an
english crew that i've never worked with
uh they're getting to know me we do
night blue for the first
two nights or you know it's it's it's
literally 18 minutes and i'm like okay
we're gonna do five shots
and mind you i'm a very very fast
shooter and i'll explain how we shot
this thing um
uh
so
we got two shots i'm like okay that
sucks uh we're gonna get better
because there's too much stuff around
the problem in crews and movie sets when
there's too much [ __ ] you're going to
see your [ __ ] does it make sense
all right because we're shooting at a at
a compound and we want to hide it all
so by the end of the the shooting period
we got so good as a crew
and it was it's like a slow build and
that guy's filming i hope i'm good all
right that guy in the red right is a
good shot you got a good shot great okay
um
i'm going to check it later all right
when you walk outside but by the way he
he really might check it later
being very sincere
all right so
by the end of our our our period working
together as a crew we were so well oiled
because i literally had
we would we'd get to the set at three
o'clock i'd walk everyone through i said
at 802 we are on rooftop a
80803 we do rooftop b shot at 808067
whatever everything was to the minute
we would end up in 18 minutes getting 22
shots i mean it was insane
and it was like
and they got so good at it um when you
watch that movie because you get that
beautiful like kind of cobalt thing in
the sky it was pretty neat but that's
only capable with digital cameras and i
read sort of sponsors me or they do
sponsor me and they so much of me
fincher
and they let they let me design uh
a camera they call it bayhem or whatever
uh
uh it's it's it's it's a they spent
about eight hundred thousand dollars
developing it it's a handheld camera
ergonomic and it's so small
um
and uh is this the komodo camera well
the komodo is a new thing that's a new
thing and they this is funny they they
go they go what do you want to paint you
want to paint it black
red and i'm like
jared who owns a company um
i said
i said well if you're giving me a free
camera for 800 000
and it's like an advertising thing they
weren't ever selling it i said well
let's just paint it [ __ ] you green okay
nike green
and it's become that's uh they paint
that that nike green which is like that
tape that nice neon tape right there
that's kind of what they uh
uh so they did that for me and uh
you know we keep developing the sensors
and it gets better and
uh there you go i want to jump backwards
for a second because uh i love the rock
and
i loved your work
basically i never directed the rock that
was
no i went oh no i'm kidding i was gonna
be like dude you
uh i want to know what you can share
about uh sean
sean okay okay let me explain the very
first uh uh day working with sean
connery all right i'm still a kid
shawn's done 75 movies i've done
this was my second
and we're doing the interrogation scene
with his long gray hair and the beard
and i was so scared to give him his
first direction so we do one take okay
all right let's do it again just take
and i'm like oh my god i gotta go from
some direction right now
um sean
can you um
uh just say that less charming he goes
sure boy sure boy
so my name on the set was boy okay
and
he's a director eater he hates directors
for some reason
i remember i was like down on my knees
and effects were not that good during
the rock uh at that time and i used to
be i wanted to be a magician i really
didn't make that much money i knew i
would never beat david copperfield but i
did magic for birthdays when i was a kid
okay
but i had a big quarter like a
large size quarter and i put a wire in
it
like a steel bar
and i would spin it towards the camera
so it looks like there's a scene where
he has he takes a quarter it flips on
the table and that's the thing that he
gets out of his handcuffs he kind of
hits his chair and he dents it and he
gets out of his handcuffs so i was
spinning this quarter i'm down there i'm
doing it myself and
sean connery is looking at me and he's
got this rye smile he was a tough love
guy but he liked me and i feel i learned
so much from that guy
and
um he really really taught me a lot and
he was a true true movie star and a
consummate uh worker and just his work
ethic and uh
um
i i mean i was very sad when he passed
away so i put the rock line in this
movie because of that i was gonna say
because you don't oh you don't reference
your other stuff in other movies like
that wait i mean i did that because a
lot like the younger generation they can
quote my movies better than i know them
[Laughter]
uh i love armageddon um and i just want
to get a little people you guys have
seen armageddon we expected i was like i
expected something on armageddon um and
obviously uh i i would like to know what
it was like working with bruce because
that that's just such an awesome film
and his performance is great
so the truth of this um i mean let's go
through some of some of the cast billy
bob thornton just got his oscar i had
ben affleck uh liv tyler owen wilson um
uh steve bashemy
uh
peter air come on we keep going um
what
oh my god i you can't believe i'm gonna
tell you how i found that guy okay um
uh and a will what is the last name
you know thickner and then pat great
okay great and then michael clark duncan
like literally
uh my casting woman was bonnie timmerman
new york
and the character was bear
and
michael i found you a beautiful guy he's
like 155 pounds
and
i'm like bonnie
she's bonnie's like this doll like
bonnie it says bear it says bear
and but michael he's beautiful i'm like
true story and so i i hired my uh this
woman who did commercials and videos of
me and she found this guy at a gym all
right he had never done anything he came
in to the casting session
and he's huge okay and
um
i know we're sidetracking right now but
uh he's there at the casting and bro
jerry bruckheimer uh
and they are sitting there and he's like
he starts crying oh my god my mama is
just like she would be so proud that i'm
here talking i love your movies but i
don't know and i was like just calm down
like let's let's try it
and
the guy was great okay cut to first day
working with him
with
ben affleck we're in the uh what he
called the armadillo okay
and
what what what i loved about duncan mike
duncan
my clark duncan was
the charm and just being real and he was
a lovable guy
and i like working with real people
and turning them into actors and he just
he had this voice and he was just it was
like a bad b or c actor and i'm like
dude and ben's like oh mike what are we
doing it was first take second thing i'm
like oh my god we're in trouble and i'm
like mike
i want you to just be you pretend it's
just you talking
and
he became the most studied actor in
terms of
he came he came literally the farthest
because he watched bruce he watched
everyone everyone sort of took him under
his wing
and
then the last movie he did green mile
right we was up for an oscar i mean
and uh
you know i i i remember telling him in
the psychology exam
uh i do that with all my actors i give
him a psychology exam no i'm kidding i'm
kidding in the psychology exam in the
movie uh i said i want you to cry he
said mike i can't do that i said mike
you can't they will love you
no i can't and he just started crying
and it's like he's great
i was very sad when you pass and and
then bruce willis
bruce
it was a fun fun cast
uh it was almost like i felt like a camp
counselor because everyone was joking
around the entire time but bruce came in
a month after we were shooting and um uh
he was tough he was tough he wanted to
what i realized psychology but actors
it's always psychology and he just
wanted to feel like top dog because
everyone was there for a month everyone
was sort of friends and then bruce comes
in and he wanted to kind of assert
himself and i'm a young that's my third
movie and um
i'm young and
i i was i was about 17 at that time
because i'm 32 now
um uh
there's a reason why i keep saying 32
all right and let me just i'll get that
out of the way the great howard stringer
who ran sony
uh he was knighted by the queen and he i
said how old are you howard and he goes
michael michael we're all 32. i'm like
that's a great philosophy all right so
there we go
um
so uh bruce
was tough and the picture slowed down to
just a stall like was like we were
shooting at a clip and then said
because he wanted to assert himself
to jerry bruckheimer my producer it was
fantastic he said
show him just show him some some footage
so three weeks four weeks in i showed
him some footage
and
bruce goes oh man i would have been a
lot nicer if you showed me earlier
because actors just need to trust their
directors and uh i loved working with
bruce uh he was a real he was he is
and was a real movie star um you know i
was inspired by um
i'm spacing on the name because i've
been talking for nine hours today um um
come on uh the building come on
die hard okay there we go are you gonna
be like nakatomi plaza what one of the
great action movies i heard
um bruce willis uh was funny
he he has a great power of the he just
holds the camera's attention and
i really liked working with them really
did